Kylie Jenner poses for Vanity Fair Italy
and reveals her favorite sister and the
sister she's least like I can't the
beauty Mogul opens up to the mag about
her famous fam dishing on all things
Kardashian Jenners like which of her
four sisters is her fave quote it
changes over time right now it's Kim I
love that Kylie explains that Kim has
changed so much recently and adds they
are very connected she is always the
first sister I call when I need
something we have been going through a
lot of similar experiences lately you
just gotta roll with it while Kylie
doesn't elaborate on what those
experiences are it might just be their
high profile splits last month the
source told ET that Kylie and Travis
Scott are on a break they share two
children together a five-year-old
daughter stormy and a one-year-old son
air you'll never know a deer how much I
love you quote the two have had an up
and down relationship and although they
aren't together right now it doesn't
mean it's over for good what color are
my eyes
uh green sometimes yellow
of course Kim has gone through her own
a father of her four children Kanye West
the two finalized their divorce in
November 2022 and a month later she got
emotional talking about the aftermath I
don't want to get emotional no it's just
been a day for me
but like it's been a time it has been
you know it's hard
it's like co-parenting it's really hard
you know but back to Kylie thank you
well she told the mag she's super tight
with Kim she admitted the sister she has
the least in common with is Kendall
without a doubt you know what they say
though Opposites Attract and that's how
it works with us it's super enjoyable
it's kind of hard not to have fun as for
what she's learned from her sisters
Kylie says Chloe has taught her
tenderness and the ability to forgive
Kendall the importance of friendship and
unconditional love Courtney the value of
health and not being superficial and Kim
the ability to always tell yourself that
you can do it come what may I think I
put pressure on myself which I I love
that energy in my life because that's
who I am Kylie calls Kim really strong
and really resilient and safe to say the
same can be said for the Kylie Cosmetics
founder billionaire and Mom of two Kylie
baby number two congratulations thank
you Kylie recently celebrated her son's
first birthday and finally revealed his
name air Kai and Travis originally named
him wolf a choice Kylie said she made in
a rush before leaving the hospital I
liked the name I don't think anything I
still like this I love it I love it I
like wolf I just wasn't
now Kylie is reflecting on the future
dishing on where she wants to be in 10
years maybe I will want to have more
children I would certainly like to grow
as a person and devote myself more to
charitable Endeavors it is important to
give back some of the good fortune you
receive
[Music]
thank you